even though we all have 365 days in a
year what if I told you the average
person last year lost
180 days simply because they don't know
how to handle conflicts when I break it
down to you it's going to make all the
sense of the world
[Music]
so stick around to the very end I got a
PDF for you to look at with today's
content as well as a quiz to take to
find out what drives you so let's get
right into a look when it comes on to
conflict most conflicts in your life
happen because of a personality and
there's really three different people in
your life you deal with one are people
you directly report to that are superior
to you your boss your investor your
board your father anybody that is above
you that has some kind of a leadership
role over you that's one type of a
personality they challenge you they push
you they expect more from you that
generates conflict the other types of
people you have conflicts but are people
at the same level as you this could be
your brother your sibling your best
friend your co-worker somebody at the
same level as you that you're having
conflicts with then those that are below
you somebody that reports direct to you
your kids it could be an employee it
could be a client any of that stuff that
reports to you you're having conflicts
well so now if you look at it from this
perspective people you report to your
people at the same level as you or
people below you which one of them did
you have the most conflicts with in
2022. by the way I want you to think
about the three names this year that
caused you the most headache was it your
spouse was it your boss was it somebody
reports to you what was it make a list
of those three names when you think
about those three names look for
commonalities do all three of them
generally fall in the same category
people that report to you for people
that you were co-worker with or people
that you're poor too if you do see a
trend you will notice you have a
challenge with one of those three or two
of those three either you don't know how
to work with people above you because
and you know this yourself you know a
lot of people everybody wants to blame
their boss but maybe you don't know how
to deal with them and you got to learn
how to work with them better it's either
going to be somebody that that's a cool
same level as you're below you here's
the one thing the people that are above
you if you're having a hard time working
with I was just watching a video by 50
Cent he said something very powerful
good friend of mine Robert Greene wrote
a book called 48 Laws of Power it's a
book that not a lot of people recommend
but they read it's one of those books
make sure nobody else reads it but I
gotta read them myself and I hope nobody
else reads it and you'll see a lot of
people reference stories from that book
but they don't want to recommend the
book you know what's number one law in
that book 40 Laws of Power written by
Robert Greene never outshine my master
he uses the word Master now obviously
that's like your report Your Leader your
CEO your father whoever it is right and
50 Cent says he reports too who found
him in the lead Eminem did who found
Eminem Dre Eminem always respects Dre 50
always respects M you know who else he
talked about when he talks about Drake
he says I told Drake I always tell Drake
hey always respect Wayne anytime you're
around him never outshine him always
give the love to him because what that
is a very important relationship to take
care of okay because you want to have a
good relationship here because more
loyalty they have to you the more
they're doing behind closed doors for
you the more they're threatened by you
the less they want to do for you behind
closed doors so you got to always give
the respect here if it's a person at
this level maybe you're not you're super
competitive which is fine but you're not
collaborative maybe you got to figure
out a way to have a better relationship
here with your sibling if it's your best
friend whatever it could be there's a
different approach to take here and then
those that go down maybe you're not that
good of a leader maybe you're a little
too rough on your guys maybe you don't
inject belief on that maybe you don't
know that anytime you start to criticize
somebody always start off by saying what
they're doing right then feed the
criticism and then finish it with
lifting them up and saying Hey listen I
want you and I still believe in you this
is just one mistake we're going to get
better but I believe in you've done a
great job the one saying that I heard 17
years ago by a movie Mary Poppins and
she would say the following line just a
spoon full of sugar makes the medicine
go down the medicine go down if the
medicine is criticism and feedback Give
a Little Sugar I believe in you you've
done a great job maybe you need your
approach needs to get a little bit
better when you're working with people
below you now here's the other game that
we're going to be playing those three
names that I had you thinking about how
many days did you lose in 2022 because
of those three people because you don't
know how to handle conflict with those
types of people your relationship with
your boss your relationship with a
direct report to you your relationship
with somebody that's at the same level
as you how many days did you lose
sleepless nights not coming into work
with a good attitude you just had a bad
attitude at times you were frustrated
your mind was preoccupied you didn't
sell as good as you typically do you
didn't produce as good as you do you
didn't handle issues as you as good as
you typically do you didn't show up to
meetings that you typically do because
your mind is preoccupied so you could
have typically come out of nine but
because you're thinking about you came
out of six those are lost days those
lost Days end up being lost to revenue
days lost Dollar Days lost growth days
what did that cost you last year okay we
did this exercise with few hundred
business owners that are doing anywhere
between a million to 100 million dollars
per year year and you saw the answers
these are people that are
multi-millionaires May last you one guy
who does 40 million a year he says I
lost
270 days last year wife is sitting right
next to him saying I agree maybe more
because that's all he ever talked about
he could not handle one conflict with a
direct report another person I lost 180
days another person I lost 95 days these
are professional millionaires that are
losing those steps of days how many days
did you lose so you may have had 365
days but you ended up only really having
60 days of high productivity days
because you don't know how to handle
some of these personalities that are
working with you so you I don't know the
I'm not sitting down right now knee
Captain kneecap with you to say here's
how to deal with these personalities you
know who those people are in your life
and you got to come up with a better
strategy in your life because if there's
a goal that I have every year going into
2023 and I did this years ago because
back in the days somewhat happened I
would lose a month and a half two months
and I'm just thinking I'm so frustrated
about I'm like I can't afford to do this
anymore so I put a goal for myself you
know what it was every year I cannot
lose only single digit days which is
nine not not 11 days not 28 days not 73
days I can only lose nine days that's
the permission I give myself no more
than nine days that came up so what
happens you gotta address the conflict
sooner you got to make the call you got
to get ahead of it you gotta sit down in
front of them you got to ask them what's
bothering them you got to share with
them what bothered you you got to share
with them with your expectations so
nothing's being dead weight the more you
do that up front rather than sitting on
it and saying I'm not gonna call that
person I'm not going to do this you're
just costing yourself a third of the
year half of you it's just not worth it
it's hurting your life it's hurting your
joy it's hurting your peace of mind and
it's hurting your career no matter what
business you're in CEO founder executive
manager employee support doesn't matter
what role you're playing it's affecting
your life so having said that I got a
PDF for you to download so you can write
down the names and really calculate how
many days you lost and also share this
with the employees your teammates your
family members click here it's also
going to be in the description number
two if you want to take a quiz to learn
more about your personality you may not
even know how you are on why some
personalities are having a hard time
working with you there's four
personalities one of them is
individuality which are driven about
what things are for you two's
advancement three is purpose four is
madness click here to take the quiz or
go to pbdquiz.com and you'll find out
after I think it's like 25 questions
you're gonna learn a lot about yourself
having said that take care everybody
bye-bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]